Caption: um
Caption: welcome to my session my name is megan
Caption: pusey and i am presenting on how to
Caption: design tutorials that your users won't
Caption: ignore
Caption: first off i want to say
Caption: uh thank you to the sponsors for ddd
Caption: perth without whom this event couldn't
Caption: happen and i also wanted to acknowledge
Caption: the traditional custodians of the land
Caption: that we are meeting on today which is
Caption: the logic people of the nonga nation
Caption: and
Caption: pay respects to their elders past
Caption: present and emerging so a little bit
Caption: about me
Caption: i am just finishing my phd at murdoch
Caption: university and my phd has been in it and
Caption: education so my background's in
Caption: education and i've um my phd's all been
Caption: about user research so i'm sort of
Caption: bringing that background to this talk to
Caption: talk about how people learn how our
Caption: brains work and how we can design for
Caption: that better more broadly for apps web
Caption: games whatever it might be so that the
Caption: onboarding and tutorial process is as
Caption: smooth as possible
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: bad news i'm afraid my title is a bit of
Caption: a misnomer in that
Caption: we can't actually force people to do
Caption: something they don't want to do so your
Caption: users may still ignore your tutorials
Caption: but we're going to hopefully uh show you
Caption: some tricks
Caption: on how to put that information into your
Caption: products such that your users can find
Caption: it and still navigate and successfully
Caption: use your product even if they do
Caption: end up ignoring the initial tutorial
Caption: so first i wanted to talk about working
Caption: memory and how our memory works we have
Caption: short-term long-term memory and a
Caption: working memory which helps us when we
Caption: need to remember things
Caption: to carry out a task and when we're
Caption: learning something new
Caption: um we are using our memory so for this
Caption: task i want to showcase to you the
Caption: limitations of our working memory i'm
Caption: going to put up 11
Caption: digits or 11 numbers
Caption: and without writing them down
Caption: i'd like you to try and memorize them
Caption: i'll give you a few seconds
Caption: for those who can't see them the numbers
Caption: are 3 1 4
Caption: 1 9 four five six zero zero eight
Caption: all right got that
Caption: how many can you remember can you
Caption: remember all
Caption: the whole sequence of eleven
Caption: maybe you can remember the first few and
Caption: the last few generally that's what
Caption: happens when we try and remember things
Caption: um but it's really tricky to remember
Caption: irrelevant
Caption: disconnected pieces of information
Caption: and i just gave you random numbers there
Caption: so one way we can make that easier on
Caption: our memory and the way our brain works
Caption: is to group
Caption: numbers together or pieces of
Caption: information together in categories so
Caption: that instead of trying to remember 11
Caption: things we're just remembering three
Caption: things and if we give it meaning or
Caption: purpose it is instantly a lot easier to
Caption: remember for example the first four
Caption: numbers were the first four digits of pi
Caption: 94.5 is a radio station in perth and
Caption: 6008 is the postcode for subiaco so in
Caption: that case we have something to link it
Caption: to our memory instead of just trying to
Caption: remember 11 random pieces of information
Caption: um with remembering phone numbers these
Caption: are made up for numbers
Caption: we often grip them in chunks
Caption: so you might mentally recognize that
Caption: you're grouping phone numbers in chunks
Caption: rather than trying to remember 11 or 9
Caption: pieces of information so what that means
Caption: for design is it's better if you give
Caption: the tutorial or onboarding onboarding
Caption: process meaning for example this is from
Caption: duolingo which is a language learning
Caption: app they're asking you right at the
Caption: start why are you using this app
Caption: so they're segmenting their users and
Caption: offering them a different onboarding
Caption: experience based on why they're there to
Caption: make it more meaningful to the user
Caption: we also want to try to
Caption: avoid over taxing the memory and just
Caption: provide information
Caption: just in time when it is needed
Caption: a wall of text right at the start is not
Caption: the way to go in onboarding and
Caption: tutorials people will ignore that
Caption: whereas if you provide them the
Caption: information when it's meaningful it's a
Caption: lot more effective another example of
Caption: providing information just in time this
Caption: is an app for coding a robot that they
Caption: use in education
Caption: for the dash and dot robots
Caption: this is the code and you press start
Caption: down the bottom left to send the code
Caption: via bluetooth to the robot however in
Caption: this case i wasn't connected to a robot
Caption: and it was only after i pressed the
Caption: start button that this prompt appeared
Caption: asking me to connect to the robot so the
Caption: information appeared at the time i
Caption: needed it because it recognized i had
Caption: not connected to a robot so it wasn't
Caption: going to work
Caption: unfortunately people still forget things
Caption: very very easily so you will need to
Caption: remind them and unfortunately by the end
Caption: of this talk about 20 minutes you'll
Caption: probably only remember about 60 of what
Caption: i said and by tomorrow that will be down
Caption: to 30
Caption: so if you have repeat users even after
Caption: being a first-time user you're still
Caption: going to need to remind them of key
Caption: features um or room or showcase new
Caption: features or things that have changed
Caption: within your app this is an example of
Caption: the linkedin app
Caption: and a little tooltip that appeared when
Caption: they first introduced reactions to a new
Caption: feature
Caption: but i noticed my banking app was also
Caption: using this sort of thing when i logged
Caption: in because they had moved one of the
Caption: menu icons and so the next few times
Caption: they logged in it reminded me that that
Caption: icon had moved so reminders for repeat
Caption: users are still really important people
Caption: forget things very very easily
Caption: moving on to attention
Caption: uh
Caption: how long do you think your attention
Caption: span actually is
Caption: are you still paying attention to what
Caption: i'm saying uh
Caption: apparently our attention spans are only
Caption: about eight seconds some of the research
Caption: has said but um i know from myself
Caption: personally in this sort of one-way
Caption: communication setting it only takes
Caption: about 10 to 15 minutes for my brain to
Caption: start wandering and thinking about what
Caption: i'm going to be buying at the grocery
Caption: store that afternoon
Caption: uh so i have a little demonstration i'd
Caption: like to show you about attention don't
Caption: worry it's only one minute and 40
Caption: seconds
Caption: the monkey business illusion
Caption: count how many times the players wearing
Caption: what pass the ball
Caption: the correct answer is 16 passes
Caption: did you spot the gorilla
Caption: anyone for people who haven't seen or
Caption: heard about a video like this before
Caption: about half missed the gorilla
Caption: if you knew about the gorilla you
Caption: probably saw it but did you notice the
Caption: curtain changing color or the player on
Caption: the black team leaving the game
Caption: let's rewind and watch it again
Caption: here comes the gorilla and there goes a
Caption: player the curtain is changing from red
Caption: to gold
Caption: when you're looking for a gorilla you
Caption: often miss other unexpected
Caption: and that's the monkey business illusion
Caption: learn more about this
Caption: the monkey business solution let's skip
Caption: it so
Caption: that phenomenon has been studied and is
Caption: called inattentional blindness which
Caption: means even if something is right in
Caption: front of you
Caption: you can still miss it especially if
Caption: you're not expecting to look for that
Caption: information so even as a designer if you
Caption: think well the information's all there
Caption: surely they saw it
Caption: no
Caption: sometimes users can still miss vital
Caption: things even though it's right in front
Caption: of them so don't assume that everything
Caption: that is on the screen is being paid
Caption: attention to
Caption: one way to help
Caption: uh design around the attention aspect is
Caption: to provide information on demand so that
Caption: if a user missed that piece of
Caption: information they could always access it
Caption: later on when it's needed
Caption: for example um just an example from last
Caption: week for me i was filling in an online
Caption: form it's not pretty looking but that's
Caption: not the point
Caption: next to the fields was a question mark
Caption: symbol a lot of uh fields or forms to
Caption: use this now whereby i could click the
Caption: question mark to find out more
Caption: information about what was required in
Caption: this field so if i'd forgotten what an
Caption: acm citation reference was i could click
Caption: on the question mark and find out
Caption: exactly what they were after so i'm not
Caption: having to remember that piece of
Caption: information if i wasn't paying attention
Caption: and i forgot what that word meant i
Caption: could easily go and find out and it was
Caption: in context with the field so i didn't
Caption: have to go to a whole separate glossary
Caption: page to find that information
Caption: another example of this is
Caption: just yesterday i opened up a new asana
Caption: account just to show you the first time
Caption: user experience down the bottom left is
Caption: a help in getting started
Caption: menu that you can click and it brings up
Caption: this whole extra section on the left
Caption: here with highly detailed information
Caption: about how to get started or how to do
Caption: certain tasks on asana their initial
Caption: introduction just asks you what you're
Caption: there for why you want to use it and
Caption: helps you set it up and get gets you
Caption: going very quickly and then they leave
Caption: the in-depth stuff till later on because
Caption: they know you just want to get started
Caption: using the product and you're not going
Caption: to be paying attention to all the finer
Caption: details and features of that product at
Caption: that time
Caption: another key thing that really helps with
Caption: our i guess lack of paying attention is
Caption: giving feedback on user actions be that
Caption: positive or negative feedback both are
Caption: equally important so
Caption: recently i was trying to earlier this
Caption: year trying to enroll my daughter in
Caption: after school care not this after school
Caption: care but this was the form
Caption: each field had a feedback as to whether
Caption: i had filled in correctly or not so a
Caption: tick for yes you've done this field
Caption: correct uh red circle with the dash
Caption: through it for no you haven't done this
Caption: one correctly yet the submit button was
Caption: also grayed out and i could not select
Caption: it until i had filled in everything
Caption: successfully however in this my case i
Caption: had filled everything in successfully as
Caption: far as i knew and i still couldn't
Caption: submit couldn't figure out why i got
Caption: very frustrated emailed tried to email
Caption: and call as well to figure out what was
Caption: going on
Caption: only a few days later just by
Caption: happenstance i
Caption: was talking to someone in the school
Caption: community and they oh that after school
Caption: club closed down at the end of 2020 but
Caption: that information was nowhere on the
Caption: website it was still available to select
Caption: as a service name and the service email
Caption: didn't even have an automatic reply to
Caption: tell me they were no longer operating so
Caption: there was no feedback to me
Caption: to let me know that i could i'm not
Caption: going to be able to complete this action
Caption: because that service doesn't exist
Caption: anymore i went back just the other day
Caption: to get this screenshot and the service
Caption: isn't on there anymore
Caption: so you can't try and enroll for it but
Caption: that to me i had no idea why
Caption: i could not successfully complete this
Caption: action and that was very frustrating for
Caption: me
Caption: the last thing i wanted to cover
Caption: and talk about was
Caption: misinterpretation so
Caption: in my background i do a lot of
Caption: communicating work speaking teaching and
Caption: anytime you communicate an idea there
Caption: will always be someone who misinterprets
Caption: it unfortunately so these tips are more
Caption: about trying to reduce misinterpretation
Caption: i don't think you'll ever will ever be
Caption: able to design a product with no
Caption: misinterpretation
Caption: to start with there's just plain bad ui
Caption: i was filling in a form the other day
Caption: three simple yes no questions that i
Caption: really didn't want to get wrong but i
Caption: found it really hard to tell which radio
Caption: button was yes and which was no and i
Caption: was a little confused and i still don't
Caption: know i'm assuming i picked yes
Caption: but i'm still not quite sure and that
Caption: was purely due to bad ui so obviously
Caption: testing uh your products on and this was
Caption: on desktop not mobile mobile mobile's
Caption: often where the problems are this was
Caption: desktop
Caption: so testing your products can avoid most
Caption: of these simple problems
Caption: um but i wanted to talk about
Caption: other issues around misinterpretation of
Caption: icons so if you have a piece of paper
Caption: i'd like you to quickly draw whatever
Caption: first comes to mind for the shapes
Caption: diamond
Caption: and cross
Caption: if you don't have a piece of paper
Caption: that's okay you can just imagine in your
Caption: head
Caption: what you would have drawn
Caption: for those words diamond and cross you
Caption: can also compare
Caption: your drawings or answer with the person
Caption: next to you and see if you've got the
Caption: same thing
Caption: i've run some activities with large
Caption: groups of people and it's really
Caption: interesting that these two really simple
Caption: words can mean
Caption: more than one thing even though you
Caption: think oh yeah that's straightforward a
Caption: diamond
Caption: should look like
Caption: this
Caption: or a diamond should look like
Caption: or perhaps if you're a
Caption: young child maybe your diamond looks
Caption: like this
Caption: that's from minecraft um
Caption: for a cross you know maybe if you're a
Caption: teacher like me you might think of it
Caption: across like that but you could also
Caption: think of a cross like this
Caption: or even like this
Caption: so it's possible for even very simple
Caption: things that you think are very
Caption: straightforward to be misinterpreted
Caption: to get around
Caption: this sort of issue the best way is to
Caption: represent this information in as many
Caption: ways different ways as possible so text
Caption: visual and audio if possible
Caption: uh
Caption: another example as i was playing a game
Caption: recently and they had used this acronym
Caption: rmb for one of the buttons
Caption: they did explain it at in full at the
Caption: start but obviously i had not paid
Caption: proper attention and it kept taking me a
Caption: few seconds every time i saw this
Caption: acronym to realize what button it was
Caption: referring to it's not a common acronym
Caption: most other
Caption: games and services i use use this symbol
Caption: as well alongside and immediately that's
Caption: a lot clearer to more users that you're
Caption: referring to the right mouse button
Caption: and if possible audio and you know if
Caption: it's an audio description of text
Caption: fantastic if it's not text you could
Caption: have even audio feedback on an action um
Caption: to help
Caption: with interpretation
Caption: so tips on avoiding misinterpretation is
Caption: know your audience know where they're
Caption: coming from know what they expect to see
Caption: and use that
Caption: if you're not sure use some user testing
Caption: with your target audience even user
Caption: testing on as little as five people
Caption: can
Caption: explore and show
Caption: a lot of basic issues so you can get rid
Caption: of them before releasing a product and
Caption: allow for error recovery which means
Caption: if users make a mistake which will
Caption: happen allow them to undo that mistake
Caption: or ask them if they're really sure they
Caption: want to delete that very important file
Caption: um so with knowing your audience uh
Caption: this happened in my house the other day
Caption: and to me and to you it might look like
Caption: a glass of water with some weeds in it
Caption: um
Caption: which i was about to throw on the bin
Caption: but my daughter informed me it was a
Caption: bouquet of flowers she had picked at the
Caption: park for me and that was the bars so you
Caption: know know your audience
Caption: um
Caption: this symbol appears a lot lately and to
Caption: me i had just called it the menu icon
Caption: i'm not sure if you have a different
Caption: name for it uh but recently i heard
Caption: there was another name for it that i had
Caption: never heard before which was the burger
Caption: um but what i liked in this particular
Caption: this is
Caption: my daughter's school's canteen ordering
Caption: system rather than say click the burger
Caption: icon to order which could be very
Caption: confusing in this context they said tap
Caption: here with the symbol to start ordering
Caption: and the user can actually click on this
Caption: icon or up in the top left corner so
Caption: both options are available
Caption: an example of error recovery
Caption: is i
Caption: can't remember which service this was
Caption: but
Caption: they let users know that even though
Caption: they had scheduled the email for in the
Caption: future they could still go back and
Caption: change the email delete or stop the
Caption: schedule or change the day and time so
Caption: that even though you've you're about to
Caption: commit to a large action of sending an
Caption: email to thousands of people you could
Caption: still
Caption: go back and change if you had made a
Caption: mistake
Caption: so in summary
Caption: for working memory provide users with
Caption: information just in time when it's
Caption: meaningful
Caption: for attention
Caption: make sure you have information available
Caption: on demand if it was missed that first
Caption: time which it most likely will be by
Caption: somebody
Caption: and give feedback both positive and
Caption: negative feedback or successful and
Caption: unsuccessful feedback on user actions
Caption: to try and avoid misinterpretation do
Caption: some basic user testing with your target
Caption: audience not your friend in the cubicle
Caption: next to you
Caption: and allow for error recovery so at least
Caption: users don't feel scared to undertake an
Caption: action because at least they know they
Caption: can go back and do it again
Caption: yeah and so i guess if you only remember
Caption: one thing tomorrow from this
Caption: presentation
Caption: i think celia hodan who is the games
Caption: user researcher puts it best where she
Caption: says
Caption: have
Caption: users learn by doing which i hope is
Caption: what we have done today through doing
Caption: those activities
Caption: in context and with purpose
Caption: if you'd like to do more reading on how
Caption: our brains work how we learn and how
Caption: that
Caption: crosses over with user design and user
Caption: experience design
Caption: these are probably my top three picks
Caption: for books um
Caption: they even though they might be specific
Caption: to a certain context a lot of what they
Caption: write about is very applicable broadly
Caption: in designing of
Caption: web apps games
Caption: and
Caption: are there any questions that's it thank
Caption: you for listening
Caption: i hope you learned something and
Caption: that's it